I'm pleased to welcome to the program
today Don Jeffries who's author of the
new book survival of the richest with
which looks at the issue of wealth
disparity and income inequality a topic
we've been talking about for a long time
Don why why do you feel this is such an
important issue in the world today
wealth disparity well I think it's the
most important issue in America and the
world when you have a disparity of
wealth we have which right now we just
recently learned that to half of America
50% earns $27,000 a year or less and we
already knew that that same half the
bottom half of Americans have less than
1% of the collective wealth I don't
think you can have a first world economy
or a first world nation with that kind
of growing to a glowing disparity of
wealth and and why not in other words in
practice what are the negative
repercussions of having such wealth
inequality well you have to have people
be able to buy things to purchase things
and if you have to understand lling
safety-net
i mean republicans especially want to
eliminate what what benefits are left
out there you have to have people be
able to survive we're not back in the
old days of being able foraging for your
own food and living off the land and so
forth so you have tons of people we also
have more people on government benefits
right now than we do have working so we
have a society we have to figure out how
we're going to handle this because
you're really going to consign people to
lives of poverty and death if they
starve to death or freeze to death and
they don't have housing or you're going
to have to come up with some kind of
universal basic income or you're gonna
have to really be serious about bringing
jobs back and bringing factories back
and having full employment so let's take
a few of those pieces one at a time I
have not heard this data about you said
there's more people on government
benefits than working today what talked
to me about that a little bit yeah that
was widely disseminated to than the last
one out of six months or years actually
probably was when I was even writing
survival of the richest it's just a fact
with all the obviously people on Social
Security there's lots of people on
Social Security disability just various
benefits getting Medicare and Medicaid
whatever and especially with the baby
boomers retiring increasingly you're
gonna eventually have not enough people
working probably to be able to support
the baby boomers so and
in other words you're in all retired
persons who receive Social Security
which of course they paid into now we
rescuing those numbers understood let's
talk about that you mentioned the
bringing back of manufacturing jobs this
has been sort of a political football
for a long time and every good analysis
I've read really points to the the
reality that a lot of those jobs that
did at some point leave the u.s. aren't
coming back because increasingly they
don't exist anymore what do you think
about that yeah I understand that's one
of the answers and that may be true and
if that is true that we can't bring back
even a sizeable portion of those old
jobs and we have to look at our
alternate especially when you look at
the artificial technology that's coming
in the the robots are going to be you're
taking who knows how many millions of
jobs so I think that's when we have to
look at that I don't mericans hate to
hear the universal basic income thing
but you have to come up with some way if
the jobs aren't there you have to have
some way for people to support
themselves in the book you talk about
how a lot of Americans don't really get
how it is that the system is rigged
against them and how there are a lot of
mechanisms that basically funnel or
channel money upward and there's a lot
of people in the US particularly on the
American right who claim to be against
the redistribution of wealth usually in
the form of using taxes on the rich to
pay for social welfare benefits for the
not rich but there's this other
redistribution that goes on all the time
that's an upward redistribution can you
talk about how that works yeah it's it's
everything I mean you look at the NFL
with all the problems they've had
recently ollie all these stadiums that
have been built at taxpayer expense I
mean this is the greatest corporate
welfare imaginable where you have
billionaires that basically come crying
to the public and say you know I want
you to build my stadium for me and
that's the the absolute opposite of us
so-called risk capitalism because
they're not taking any risks they're
basically threatening to move the team
at the public doesn't finance their
stadium and the public invariably does
even if they don't want to because their
representatives are beholden to these
billionaires and not beholden to the
people in a way they're kind of
socializing the risk of these projects
while setting themselves up to then
claim the profits as part of the
entrepreneurial capitalist system are
they not yeah socialism works for them I
mean it did work very wonderful
for them as I point out in the book also
they all kinds of rich people get tons
and tons of freebies and celebrities up
at farm subsidies and things like that
and I have the I have the you know we
can't go into it here but I have I have
all those statistics and names in my
book and it's the system is rigged for
the rich and and even the lower-class
Americans don't seem to mind that as
much if you try to talk about corporate
welfare to them they invariably talk
about their neighbor that's on food
stamps or somebody they thought the
store on food stamps or how big their TB
is that's what they're concerned about
mythical welfare queens and they don't
care about the billionaires not paying
taxes so part of being able to continue
rigging the system in this way involves
a PR campaign that as you are pointing
out puts the attention on the food stamp
recipient for example and a lot of
people in our audience probably are
familiar with you mentioned these
imaginary welfare queens the the
infamous Ronald Reagan story of a woman
with a Cadillac whatever right I don't
even remember the exact details we know
we know it's been debunked talk a little
bit about how far back this campaign
goes influencing the average American to
sort of direct their ire and anger at
the imaginary welfare queen the food
stamp recipient whoever else how far
back does that go well I think it began
in earnest under Reagan did you talk
about with with the welfare queen
campaign in the right at that time began
to change and I wanted a little bit more
of this in hitting history in my
previous book where the right change
from being anti-communist and concerned
about that to being basically an ran
disciples a lot of this that we see this
in paul ryan especially today whose hero
is an ran a lot of these Republicans are
and Ayn Rand taught that greed is good
and one of her quotes was we have no
obligation to take care of our neighbors
and these the people like yet Paul Ryan
and others are really beholden to her
belief so you can read the quotes I have
in the book about that but it's deadly
philosophy I mean parts of it are good
because in you know individual liberty
is important but when you have
individual liberty at the expense of the
whole where you just completely ignore
your neighbors which is what this
philosophy entails it's big it's kind of
a rugged individualism that might have
worked in the Wild West
but it can't work in our modern-day age
unless you want to go back to those days
and again you're gonna have people dead
in the streets and you're not gonna have
a first world country is that part of
the issue with the more sort of
absolutist libertarian ideals which when
you read about them framed in a way that
sort of eloquent and articulate it can
be very very appealing but it's sort of
divorced from the realities of humans no
longer being like in a state of nature
and having society yeah and I have a lot
of libertarian in me I mean I loved Ron
Paul and I loved the foreign policy of
libertarians I loved the fact that they
they're only people out there pretty
much you're emphasizing civil liberties
and allowing us to have our rights under
the Bill of Rights but you when you
carry it into the domestic arena they're
very unrealistic because they they act
as if you know it's in its insignificant
that half the country basically has
nothing and I stress that over and over
again that's half the country and with
each new wave of immigration that comes
in it comes in at the bottom level so
that those people entering the country
are desperately poor and so they're
making that bottom fifty percent figure
grow and grow because they're obviously
not adding any wealth of the country and
that group already has no wealth so you
have to be able to distribute that that
wealth a little bit at least a little
bit more fairly and we see back into the
Golden Age what we considered the Golden
Age of America like the 1950s the top
tax rate was ninety percent I don't want
to necessarily go back to that but
that's when things seemed to rent and
run more smoothly because the rich at
that time still had all their loopholes
and plenty they didn't play taxes but it
things were distributed more fairly and
you didn't have the CEO worker disparity
of income that we have now back then
they weren't CEOs they were presidents
of the companies many times they had
found at the country company so they had
a vested stake and an interest in it and
they also had more civic pride and they
cared a little bit more about how things
ran outside of their own profit margins
and their own size of their bonuses how
would you fix this issue because very
often you will get some buy-in when
people hear you sort of identify the
problem and let's say we get buying that
that we all agree yeah this is a problem
there's a lot of negative externalities
to such significant income and wealth
inequality we kind of agree on that
there will be a significant
that is opposed to just what they would
call unreasonable levels of Taxation in
order to redistribute so is taxation one
of the paths that you would identify is
it the path how do you fix the problem
well I'm a Huey Long disciples you know
I have a whole chapter devoted Huey Long
in the book and I really would go try to
go back to his share of the wealth
program which people don't realize they
called him a communist and so forth the
first million dollars of income and this
is in the 1930s it should be like twelve
million now would not have been taxed so
basically no one but the 1% of the 1%
win that's people don't realize how much
wealth is concentrated at the top we
don't even know because we don't know
how much wealth exactly is in these
tax-free foundations I would go after
that the way Huey long did I would also
follow the recommendations at the grace
Commission in the 1980s which found that
fully one-third of all government
spending is completely wasted so we
could cut taxes by one-third and
spending by one-third at least it's
probably more waste by now in the
ensuing years it without without anyone
you know how could anybody possibly
eject you that I would means test Social
Security I would start test taxing all
Social Security income most people don't
realize their regressive Social Security
tax well let's talk about that one
though if weekend on because so I think
that there when it comes to Social
Security there's a number of different
sort of mathematical problems we can
identify and I think that the idea of
lifting or removing the cap so for
people who don't know and you'll correct
me if I'm wrong it's around a hundred
you pay Social Security tax on the first
hundred and twenty thousand or so of
income per year is that roughly the
number 123 that's right something along
those lines anything you weren't beyond
that you no longer pay into Social
Security but of course the benefits that
you're going to get out out of Social
Security upon retirement also reach a
cap so one way to have a huge influx of
money into the Social Security system
would be to double triple quadruple or
even eliminate that cap altogether now
right I would be up for discussing that
but I think if you do that it's going to
be very difficult to also argue for
means-testing Social Security
particularly when the benefits are not
particularly extravagant I think if you
do one which I agree with I don't know
about the means-testing
part well I mean either would be great
I'd like that both but Ross Perot back
in 1992 tried to test fly the idea of
voluntary means testing as he said I
don't need Social Security and the AARP
and the the lobbies typical lobby shot
him down so I think at the very least
the people that are conscious all these
people like Warren Buffett that claim
you know tax me more whatever that at
least publicly they would have to say I
don't need Social Security Bill Gates
and so forth so I think if you again
there's no reason for those people to
have Social Security i agree
means-testing it it's a very extreme
measure but you know this this is what
happened we go back to the days of LBJ
when they first started dipping into the
Social Security Fund it was supposed to
be a separate fund and then it really
went overboard during the Reagan years
the great tax cut or tax context cut
taxes for the top one percent but he
raised Social Security taxes
dramatically and he started taxing
Social Security benefits that was it's
ironic that the great tax cutter was the
one who decided to double tax people on
Social Security and we still have that
system today so there's all these things
could be rolled back and it's not going
to be an easy fix overnight I realize a
Huey Long type fix is probably
impractical but people just kind of roll
your eyes when you say that but we need
something with it we need something to
try to get the wealth out spread out to
the great mass of people and you have to
go where the wealth is so any any kind
of conventional tax system that the
Democrats would devise is not gonna work
because you have that's why Huey Long
was so dangerous to people because he
wasn't like an FDR and LBJ or Bill
Clinton or Barack Obama he wanted to go
right after the absolute top one percent
and that's why if you look at the quotes
about him today the left can't stand him
when they he should have been there
ideal hero but he wasn't because he he
wasn't playing this game or creating a
big bureaucracy in middlemen and so
forth and we could see the the war on
poverty if it had actually been waged
correctly the way obj was going to wage
it it would have been won and not lost
so dramatically as it has been done the
book is fascinating it's called survival
of the richest we've been speaking with
the book's author Don Jeffries thanks so
much for talking to us today so thanks
for having me